il y a de la vie dans chaque mot
chaque mot évolue
chaque mot se met en mouvement et se
transforme pour devenir le reflet d'une
idée
mais parfois comme un tissu qui perdrait
son visage ou un fruit qui perdrait sa
saveur
il arrive qu'un mot perdre son sens
vous allez me dire tiens
le progrès c'est ça le futur
de quoi tu veux nous parler de la
grammaire
oui mais
lorsqu'il s'agit d'un mot comme le
travail
la perte de sens n'affecte pas
uniquement le degré de précision
et elle s'arrête pas à la phrase où il
est employé
la perte de sens d'un mot comme le
travail
affecte l'estime d'un être humain
et ainsi peut affecter sa santé mentale
et physique
bonsoir à tous je m'appelle Abdallah et
je suis un assembleur de mots
je les assemble pour informer pour
inspirer et parfois même pour provoquer
le plaisir
notamment lorsque je vais dans ces cas
parisienne lumière tamisée chacun et
chacune vient se lancer avec le tableau
je parle du mot des communes
la semaine je suis un orateur et le
weekend un humoriste
et vous savez quoi
je n'ai jamais cherché à le devenir
je n'ai jamais prononcé cette fameuse
phrase quand j'étais le grand je veux
parler de mon des gens
pourtant
qu'est-ce que je fais ce soir et je vais
faire avec plaisir et patient
comme j'irai demain dans un comique de
deuxième arrondissement de Paris
faire des blagues devant des inconnus
toujours avec plaisir et passion
je vois déjà la question qui vous
brûlait l'air
c'est donc ton travail que de t'exprimer
devant un public
si vous le permettez je répondrai à
cette question à la fin de mon
intervention
parce que j'aimerais y apporter la
réponse la plus juste et la plus fidèle
au sens du mot travail
qu'avez-vous si je ne précipite réponse
en réfléchir je risque de faire la même
erreur commise il y a 10 ans
il a 10 ans j'étais un jeune diplômé
d'école de commerce
je cocher toutes les cases de l'article
du jeune diplômé un fort désir de
réussite
un dynamisme parfois accessible
et une naïveté
qui serait passé Candide de Voltaire
pour un grand esprit critique
à l'époque
je savais qu'il y avait une tension
sémantique entre le mot travail et en
quoi
et je ne connaissais pas tous les sens
du mot travail et en particulier
ce sens-là
un des premiers sens du mot travail
vient de cet instant précis que nous
avons tous connu d'une manière ou d'une
autre
le sens du mot travail ici
est lié à un acte et un don de soi
extraordinaire
un moment où l'être humain va puiser
dans sa force son courage sa
persévérance pour mettre au monde à
mettre nouveau
pour accomplir une création pour voir
enfin le fruit de son labeur se mettre
en mouvement dans le monde
et c'est en ignorant ce sens du mot
travail que j'ai commencé
ma recherche d'emploi il y a 10 ans oui
je fais exprès d'intégrer à nouveau
insidieusement
car c'est comme ça que la confusion et
le non sens s'installe dans nos
carrières et prennent place
en utilisant de manière interchangeable
deux mots
qui ont des réalités et des sens
différents
travail et emploi
pour nous dire j'étais quand même
candide à l'époque mais je savais
pertinemment que travail et emploie
n'était pas synonyme
sauf erreur de ma part vous n'avez
jamais entendu quelqu'un vous dit ouh là
rejoignez d'emploi aujourd'hui
[Musique]
comme vous n'avez jamais reçu un message
d'un ami vous disant je suis désolé pour
le retard je sors tout juste de l'emploi
j'arrive
non c'est toujours le travail qui est
privilégié
et pourtant
lorsque j'ai commencé ma recherche
d'emploi je sentais déjà une première
tension
mais je ne voulais pas aller à contre
sens du groupe
le biais de normalité a pris le dessus
et je ne suis pas posé plus de questions
que ça alors je cherche un emploi au
lieu de chercher un travail
j'ai fini par obtenir une proposition
d'un grand cabinet d'audit
le genre de cabinet qui se fait appeler
B oui c'est le ministère intellectuel
[Musique]
parce que jour après jour petit à petit
la tension sémantique entre le mot
emploi et le mot travail devenait de
plus en plus tangible de plus en plus
forte de plus en plus réel
d'abord à travers un manque total dans
le connaissances il était difficile de
reconnaître et de retrouver la promesse
vendue par ce cabinet pendant les
entretiens et les événements à la
journée
ensuite à travers une comptabilité à
géométrie variable qui rendait quasi
impossible de l'agrandissement je ne
parle pas des écritures comptables
rassurez-vous c'est juste une analogie
pour exprimer la différence qu'il y
avait entre le soin mythique on le pour
comptabiliser les heures de présence de
chacun et chacune et l'absence des
tensions pour comptabiliser les manques
de respect
l'agressivité latente et les éthiques
punitives qui étaient imminentes
mais la tension et l'anti mobile ont
atteint leur paroxysme
le jour
Amélie
une collaboratrice compétente
cachée délibérément ses premiers mois de
grossesse
par peur des conséquences et de
représailles qui pourraient avoir sur
son évolution en tant qu'employé dans ce
cadre
son emploi
aller à l'encontre de son futur travail
son emploi et son futur travail à ce
moment précis avait deux sens contraire
son emploi qui est un moyen de
subsistance une source de prestige
social
devenait un poids et l'empêcher de vivre
pleinement son futur travail
vivre pleinement la joie et le
soulagement de voir la vie qu'elle porte
s'exprimer dans le monde
devant un tel l'ensemble je me suis dit
non
il doit y avoir un problème quelque part
au moins un malentendu
alors je suis parti de ce pays bon je
suis pas parti faire une retraite d'une
semaine on mangeait des pruneaux pour y
voir plus clair
[Musique]
la bibliothèque et à la bibliothèque je
me suis dit à tout à l'heure tu vas
chercher et tu vas trouver une
définition du travail qui est
intemporelle et universel une définition
qu'on pourrait partager avec n'importe
qui homme femme jeune diplômé
expérimenté une définition qu'on
pourrait partager dans 10 1000 ans
sans que personne possède une dise
vous êtes prêts
c'est une femme formidable au nom de
Simone Veil
qu'il a résumé le travail en France
c'est par le travail
que la raison saisie de le monde et
s'empare de l'imagination folle
Mesdames et Messieurs le travail est
bien plus qu'une simple occupation ou un
moyen de gagner notre vie
le travail
est une invitation en mouvement pour
développer notre raison
le travail est une voie pour stimuler
notre imagination
le travail est un phare pour trouver un
sens à notre existence dans le monde
le mot emploi n'a pas le même sens que
je sache
c'est donc normal qui ne puisse pas me
le porter
comme on voulait vous qui me suivent
vous offre quelque chose qui n'a pas
comment voulez-vous qu'une notion vous
offre quelque chose qui n'a jamais eu
c'est un peu comme demander votre chemin
à Paris un touriste
il en sait pas plus que vous le touriste
américain qui n'avez du Texas
pour lui gare de Lyon c'est à Lyon
si vous commencez à lui dire oui bien il
y a dans le deuxième arrondissement de
Paris il va mal le prendre
GSS vous dise et bah bravo Monsieur Le
humoriste
super maintenant qu'est-ce qu'on fait
qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait
j'y arrive un orateur ne laisse jamais
son public sur sa faim
je vais partager avec vous ce soir trois
trouvailles
qui permettent d'incarner les idées de
raisons de sens et d'imagination évoquée
par Simone Veil
trois trouvailles qui pourraient
faciliter la vie et le travail il y a 10
ans
et la première est
et
420000 heures moins or est un organisme
non lucratif qui réalise un travail
inestimable
le long 82 vient de vider que toutes les
personnes qui disposent en général de
80000 heures de travail dans ma vie et
que si ces heures sont orientées vers
l'arrière qui a un impact positif et
bien cela pourrait avoir un effet
significatif sur notre monde et sur
votre futur
réaliser que les heures de travail
étaient déjà ressources limitées a fait
prendre conscience de ma valeur et
surtout de ma responsabilité
j'ai arrêté de me comporter comme un
rouage qui s'offrait la durée
indéterminée et j'ai commencé à
développer des compétences utiles et
rares pour les investir plus tard j'ai
des organisations qui ont le souci de la
longévité et du bien-être des
générations futures
quand vous irez sur le site de 94 vous y
trouverez beaucoup de moyens d'études
pour construire votre parcours
professionnel
je vous conseille de commencer par les
articles sur le sujet de l'intelligence
artificielle et son orientation et aussi
regarder les articles sur la santé
mentale au travail
tous les contenus existent en texte
également le double donc le livre ou
l'écouter ou faire les deux en même
temps si ça vous industrie en d'autres
termes avec cette trouvaille vous avez
un moyen de bien investir les milliers
d'heures de travail dont vous disposez
et surtout de le faire en gardant
l'esprit que ces heures sont une
ressource limitée
dans notre futur commun à grandement
besoin
mais pour pouvoir le faire il faut y
voir d'abord plus clair n'est-ce pas
d'où la deuxième trouvaille
les premiers pas dans le parcours
professionnel ne sont ni le fruit du
hasard ni le fruit d'une réflexion bien
mûri
nos esprits sont nourris par le fantasme
professionnel et sont remplis de biais
cognitifs qui influence nos décisions
tout au long de notre carrière
pour ma part c'était le biais de
normalité
tout mon système nerveux pour vous
m'envoyez tous les messages de me dire
que je n'étais pas un place dans ce
cabinet
je me disais
non
tout le monde passe par là c'est le
métier qui rentre parce que j'entendais
dans le même space
j'avais beau assisté à des scènes ou des
collaborateurs étaient critiqués
publiquement pour ne pas dire publier
je les ai non mais surtout avec la
culture du cabinet
dans votre parcours par professionnel
vous allez rencontrer une anomalie
et il suffit que le groupe la vie
pour que c'est un malade devient partie
intégrante de votre quotidien
professionnel pour ma part j'étais juste
un vache qui cautionnait un mode de
gestion abusif sans dire à mot il suffit
que le groupe dise oui mais tu sais
c'est l'industrie c'est partout pareil
pour que vous ignoriez l'anomalie et
vous commencez à y contribuer vous-même
lorsque vous irez sur le site de
clés.org vous trouverez beaucoup
d'exercices pratiques pour améliorer
votre prise de décision et surtout des
éléments et des outils interactifs qui
vont vous permettre de mieux évaluer
votre propre façon de penser et surtout
identifier tous les biais cognitifs qui
pourraient vous influencer
je vous conseille de commencer par la
revue trimestrielle
c'est un exercice qui vous invite à
revenir sur vos expériences récentes et
d'en tirer des leçons pour le futur
maintenant que vous avez le sens que
vous voulez donner à vos ordres de
travail que vous y voyez au plus clair
qu'est-ce qui vous reste à faire
et bien il nous reste à ajouter une
dernière corde à votre arc
votre aptitude à verbaliser une pensée
et mener les autres vers leurs objectifs
d'où la troisième et dernière trouvaille
de ce soir
celle qui a changé ma vie de conduite
toast
l'objectif principal de Toastmaster est
d'aider ses membres à développer leur
confiance en eux
-mêmes et développer leur capacité à
communiquer avec efficacité que ce soit
en public ou en privé les manques de
Master en la possibilité de prononcer
des discours et de recevoir des
critiques constructives cette fois pour
grandir ses mots en tant que leader dans
un environnement d'encouragement et de
soutien
je pourrais vous parler toute la nuit
faite au spaster et de ce que cette
organisation m'a apporté mais le mieux
je pense
c'est que vous rendez visite un des
clubs qui se trouve à Paris il y a une
quinzaine de clubs dans Paris chaque
club se réunit deux fois par mois et
lors de votre première visite vous
n'êtes pas obligé de prendre la parole
mais croyez-moi
vous allez prendre la parole de manière
délibérée parce que vous aurez compris
que si un rendement vous pratiquez
comment dire c'est bien dans un
club pensez clairement grandir sainement
pour investir vos heures de travail et
les biens et bien les investibles
c'est le futur que je souhaite à chaque
personne présente ici c'est le futur que
je souhaite à votre travail et à son
sens
maintenant on arrive à la fin de mon
intervention et je vous ai promis de
répondre à la question
est-ce que c'est mon travail que de
m'exprimer devant un public
je vais rester fidèle à la citation de
Simone Veil
en effet la prise de parole en public me
permet de développer ma raison
la prise n'est pas en public ne permet
de stimuler mon imagination
mon travail ne s'arrête pas là
mon travail c'est de continuer de
cultiver
ce jardin
ce jardin ou l'autre travail sera enfin
bien employé
ce jardin
ou les survenages et la culture abusive
de gestion n'a pas sa place il sera
exclu parce que c'est le travail qui
sera privilégié ce jardin on pourra
honorer le sens et l'essence du travail
ce jardin au courant enfin dire avec
beaucoup de justesse et de fierté
le travail aujourd'hui je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]